[Music]
tonight what Oscar Pistorius said he
shouted just before he fired his gun
the secret of Mars Mars the athlete
broke down repeatedly as the prosecutor
accused him of weeping for himself
you're not using your emotional state as
an escape how are you good evening Oscar
Pistorius has faced a fourth day of
intense cross-examination in the witness
box he was picked up on alleged
inconsistencies in his account and was
accused of tailoring his version to fit
the evidence during the relentless and
detailed questioning Pistorius broke
down as he described shouting at a
purported intruder and again when
explaining why he fired his gun
the prosecutor Harry nel said those
emotions in court were not for his dead
girlfriend but because he was mixing up
his own defense Lisa Holland has been
listening to today's testimony the
strain appears to be showing for Oscar
Pistorius but his supporters were on
hand to rally the athlete as he faced
another grueling day in court
he began his second week in the witness
box with the prosecutor promising to
prove the Olympian had made up his
version of events mr. Pistorius my
argument will be and that but what the
cross-examination will focus on today is
that your version is so improbable that
it cannot be reasonably possibly true
I'm going further mr. Pistorius I'm
saying that your version of events is in
fact and true then before we start mr.
Pistorius I save got a concocted version
which you've tailored to fit the state's
case and your tailoring your version as
you sitting there you understand what
I'm saying mr. sir
the prosecutor wanted to know why reeva
Steenkamp known for being neat had all
her clothes packed except her jeans
everything else undergarments other
clothes are all in the overnight bag the
only thing outside of that overnight bag
deserved jeans you don't have an idea
why I don't my lady is my reference
anything I can think of is that she wore
the jeans that day and maybe the things
in her overnight bag Joaquin clothes I
I'm not sure isn't the reason that she
wanted to leave and wanted to get dress
that's why the denim is the jeans are
out of place she wanted to be and get
rest my lady the denims are inside off
so it would make sense that that's when
she took them off that she just left
them on the floor but what would she
leave them on the floor if everything
else that she had on everything else is
in the overnight bag why would she leave
that particular jeans outside I don't
know my lady we I'm saying and it's a
state's case mr. pastor is that she
wanted to leave
and that you weren't sleeping
you were both away that's not correct my
lady it's untrue and that there was an
argument that's not true m'lady
Harry Nell picked through Oscar
pistorius's version of events at his
Pretoria home on Valentine's Day last
year Oscar Pistorius was asked about the
moment he says he heard a noise in the
bathroom when you arm yourself and you
spoke to Eva what it what it is saying
it's harder to get down and to find the
police m'lady
in what way did you say you know
lifetime already in a lifetime
definitely did not whisper
I remember saying it in the lifetime my
lady
just as I just I left my bed I whispered
for either don't get done and phoned the
police now that is your evidence in
chief why why try to steer away from a
whisper trying to stay away from a
whisper my lady I've said before that I
remember talking in a low tone and this
morning I went ask this question I said
I think I spoke during a lifetime so if
I said I whispered there it wasn't a
whisper it was a loud tone in which I
spoke to the theme for the day daily
living over I'm putting it to you that's
what you do you're tailoring your
evidence lady fast tailoring my evidence
that would suit me to whisper not to
talk in a lot of time I don't understand
how that could be seen as tailoring my
evidence Harry now wanted to know why
the athlete hadn't asked his girlfriend
if she had also heard the noise the
noise was loud my lady twists the window
opening hands and sliding and then
hitting the door hitting the window
frame was Kia and they let's just speak
you if Reba wasn't big she would have
heard that as well that's correct at
least it would you then have expected a
conversation no saying did you hear that
oz no m'lady and I wanna seeee why would
she not have if she was there not not
because she'd heard that she would have
been as scared as I was and when I said
to get down on the floor and call the
police that's what she would have done
she wouldn't have engaged in the
conversation if she'd heard what I did
they wouldn't be a response I don't
agree with you mr. mysterious wouldn't
you expect a response from her at the
window opening in the middle of the
night whilst you invade
mr. Pistorius you just don't want to
concede anything now if you were so
convinced that it is to voice to noises
in fact a window is sliding open and
slamming into the other window
why would you not have put that in your
bio statement because that is important
when my bail will stand to stand by my
legal team was read to me in a holding
cell I was on medication I was
traumatized I read it in it was the
truth and I signed it my lady if I don't
understa it was not understanding that
it needs to be an exhausted statement
what happened next was to lead to
another breakdown in the witness box for
Oscar Pistorius as he recounted how he
made his way from the bedroom to the
bathroom via this passage where did you
start shopping
you saw solid shot sing in the passage
money yeah and and you shouted what
which the effect of what Edition which
the effect of the intruder treatise to
get out of my house with people to get
out of my house and forever to find the
police my lady but I can't remember what
you shouted you saw what variation
I said get the fun of my house are you
well enough to proceed miss Thank You
m'lady mr. patootie she just told us
what you what you shouted and then you
got emotional why would that cause you
to be emotional it's traumatic evening
for me milady what would it be traumatic
what they shouted at the intruders weak
sauce terrified milady isn't it exactly
because that's what you shot at that
River get the with respect to the court
or just repeat what you said get the god
of you out of my house that's what you
said what you shouted at Reba isn't that
why you got emotional now because I
don't understand why we get emotional if
now today about things that you shouted
at the intruders I'm traumatized by the
events and by repeating those exact
words it reminds me about tonight what I
felt some that evening at the heart of
this murder trial
why did Oscar Pistorius fire his gun and
whether he is guilty of murder we didn't
know how many people were in there
that's correct Malaysian know if they
were on correctly didn't know if it
could have been a child it's really
anyone that's gonna be in a burglar
unarmed that's correct
well like you gave them no choice you
just fired that's correct then what is
your defense
what offenses as I said one lady I heard
the noise and I don't have time to
interpreted in I fired my firearm out of
fear my lady
then out of fear by accident because I
don't understand your defense you know I
have to give a lot of answers and you
know why mr. Pistorius it's because you
you know exactly you fight at Riva these
other versions of yours cannot be true
you find a job you did why are you
getting emotional now I'm going to argue
that you got emotional because you've
got your defences mixed up and that's
the reason why you just got emotional
nothing else what do you want to say to
that we where mr. is correct and fried
and want occasion say to you you wanted
to shoot River
you didn't burst into tears you just
said no why today I do and that is
because mr. Pistorius you've got you
were I indicated to you how you got your
defences mixed up does that cause the
emotion in you nothing else I don't even
understand the differences in the
defenses I don't understand the law so
it's not for that reason that's why I
cried because you don't understand the
implications coming up Oscar Pistorius
explains why he didn't fire a warning
shot
[Music]
welcome back the state prosecutor
continued today his relentless attempt
to pull apart Oscar pistorius's account
of the events on the night that he shot
his girlfriend Karen L put it to
Pistorius that all the screams and
shouts were aimed at her behind the
bathroom door not an intruder did you
ever think of firing into the shower a
warning shot milady flash fired shots
into the shower with a ricochet possibly
hit me firing into that door in that
small toilet
a ricochet that ammunition would be
possible and it would eat somebody
am i right that's correct so you foresaw
the possibility if I fire in there and
there's somebody in there I will eat
them that's not what I said no but I
asked you did you know milady
what when you fired in there what did
you think as I said I didn't think my
farm was pointed at the door at that
time milady I didn't intend to fire my
gun my gun was pointed at the door and
when I heard the noise I fired you did
not intend to five gun your gun just
went off can we is that what we can
except for going forward in this method
no my gun didn't just go off I didn't
intend to five but I did fire but didn't
East go is it like the job that it just
got off or did you pull the trigger I
pulled the trigger m'lady because I
perceive danger to be coming out to
attack me m'lady when you want to you
fight at the danger and we don't want to
the shot just go on was it just lucky
that you grin was pointed in the
direction of whom would that be lucky
she lost to lost my lady no mr.
Pistorius you now try and enter to get
emotional again but it's not worth your
while Reva going to the toilet she would
have had to walk down a dark passage
why would you not feel unlike
I'm not sure milady she had a cellphone
with her so maybe she was using that for
luck a cellphone for life mr. poster
region
I thought your version is concerned it's
even in worse trouble you would have
seen a light walking down the passage
doesn't change anything my lady my back
was towards her doesn't matter she had a
lots will not know mr. Pistorius it's
devastating for you you would have seen
it in peripheral vision it was pitch
dark Velichko a was the first shot why
would she stand veins because Judith if
she was scared because she was talking
to you sir it's not true my lady all the
screams and shouts just screamed at her
and she flicked for a lot before I know
it I had fired four shots at the door I
kept the fire on points that in front of
me and then I slowly made my way back
check to my bed screaming why would you
ski
skiing out scared
Austria why she's fighting the police
scared that there's someone coming out
of the bathroom so then I got to the bed
you know realized Riva wasn't there I
got off if you look at the bed at the
right hand side I got off the bed I
stuck my left hand out tonight tried to
feel the curtains hoping maybe she was
hard upon him and then sorry panicking
so realized that Weaver wasn't just
replying to me if she wasn't I couldn't
see her I couldn't I couldn't share so I
went back to the bathrooms because I
couldn't got back to the entrance of the
of the bathroom Oh screaming a scream I
know scared
entering the bathroom again let's take
it much love
you told it to get down you thought she
was on the floor on the right-hand side
of the bed
she heard shots in the meantime why
would you not have lived through the
door why we could think it's River in
the bathroom if you haven't checked
every word
why because you wouldn't check
everywhere if you knew that there was
someone in the toilet well lady you
wouldn't waste time looking behind the
couch looking under the bed looking
behind the curtains
it was an intruder behind the door you
didn't
that was your perception that was my
perception
you see mr. Pistorius this is one of the
crucial issues it's a huge leap from
I've just shot at the intruders and it
could have been real you said to this
court you would excite it between the
door and the ladder
dolia letter door letter but you
approach the door without checking the
letter why not because when I thought I
was Riva my lady I wouldn't have thought
that she climbed out of the window and
even if she had I didn't fire two
windows serve my first thought was to
check the door
you can never check the ladder I never
did because once I check the door I
realized it was locked I realized there
was somebody inside but that's somebody
you cannot make the leap that it's
Reaver it could at that stage the Lapine
a intruder that's correct why did you
not check the letter first you you ain't
in love my man was with reverse why did
it was Riva good yes it could still be
an intruder but Bob man was with Riva
now you might couldn't have been with
Reba then because I'll go through every
inch of evidences at that stage I didn't
know I was still fearful of the
intruders it's political ad so you've
got a gun a cop gun you were in your
right hand you unlock the door you open
both doors and that gun was never you
never discharged that gun again
that's particularly you see mr.
Pistorius it's getting more millennia I
understand I understand hard songs but
if you look at the photos when I place
the gun down on the floor and in the
bathroom the gun was still loaded and
cocked
it was unsafe if I look back now and I
realize how much I was busy lay on the
floor I could have the gun I could have
kicked it and it could have shot me or
Eva again he said my mind wasn't
thinking about this gun in my hand why
he much no no is it about what happened
or is it about the questions and your
frustration in answering them because
now we dealt with nothing but your
version why are you getting emotional
emotional memories no it's not it you
getting frustrated because your version
is improbable and you're getting
emotional we haven't spoken about Riva
we haven't spoken about anything now but
you're getting emotional why I was
speaking about Riva milady
you're not using your emotional state as
an escape for you so you went back you
put on your prosthetic legs what
happened there but for City clicks on my
farm was next to my side on the bed from
my prosthetic legs I ran back to the
toilets I ran straight into the door
trying to shoulder charge of the door
nothing happened okay but before you go
they you took your gun a lot that's
correct
why well I would get that stage mr.
Pistorius take your gun along it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense milady
I don't know why would you see it's
because you're building a version that
is so it probably nobody would ever
believe you first building a version or
what I said I left the gun there earlier
I didn't but I understand that it
doesn't sound but rational but I didn't
have a rational sets of ma rational
frame of mind I wanted to get into the
toilet I don't know why now you see mr.
Pistorius it's because that gun was left
there after you shot and killed Riva
just off you fired the shot you left the
gun there that's what happened that's
incorrect
so the end of a fourth day of
cross-examination for Oscar Pistorius
and it hasn't got any easier mr. Nell as
relentless as ever let's find out what
Alex Crawford our correspondent and Lobo
des Nevers who's a law enforcement
expert have a think about today Alex you
were in court what did you make of it
think this is probably the worst falled
very very bad days I mean he stuttered
he stumbled he was evasive he
backtracked he contradicted he seemed to
be evolving his own evidence and
changing it doing exactly what Harry
Nell was accusing him of doing which was
tailoring it or manufacturing one to fit
the events and he was caught out on a
multitude of small detail Lobos a law
enforcement man particularly a man who
understands firearms and has spent a
lifetime investigating cases like this
what did you make of his case did he'd
add up to you I think that he's
basically lost his plea today because
it's contradicted himself it's very hard
to try and convince a court that you
acted in self-defense and then at the
same time try and convince the court
that he didn't mean to hurt anyone if we
look at the first round in isolation I
think it's now a common cause that the
first round hit the deceased in the hip
the the advisability of a person with
such a painful wound not making a single
sound is quite remote what he says is
his version story and what the state
says they believed to be the true and
the I've seen a big big contradictions
that yes I mean for the first time Harry
now is he goes at him and he's dogged in
his questioning and he's you know
insistence on the details so when he
says what did you shout and Oscar says I
don't know I'm not sure I can't remember
he insists and says insists until
finally Oscar comes up with the phrase
he shouted get the F out of my house
using a full word exploitive and the
Karen Hill turned that round to him and
saying that's not what you shouted at
the intruder that's what you shouted at
reeva Steenkamp you'd had a rao and his
hairy Nell's view of what happened was
that the two of them had a row and he
was shouting at Reva to get out of the
house and she ran tall
the toilet cubicle to get away from him
when was standing out inside the toilet
cubicle talking to him when he shot and
each time Oscar Pistorius dissolved into
tears and finally the prosecutor said
are you using your emotion to hide
behind a made-up scenario essentially
Alex died bare thanks very much for your
thoughts on day 22 the sixth day that
Oscar Pistorius is spent in the witness
box in this court he's back in there for
a seventh day tomorrow do join us from
8:30 in the morning London time at the
trial of Oscar Pistorius
[Music]